[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey chill drag your foot boy look what
we got here
[Music]
just watch me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sir as high as this river is right now
and with all the mud the sand it's
carrying well they may never find that
car
right there all right now let's hear
your story about how it wasn't our fault
yeah we were the first ones on the
bridge and coming along following the
tracks and they wanted to get around us
I guess and they lost control in the
drop you sure he didn't crowd him off
[Music]
three eyes
yeah but you want to find that going out
there's sanded with that current we may
never find guess we can do is keep
trying
[Music]
come on let's get down there
[Music]
it's Mary Henry are you alright
how'd you get out of this yeah put this
on we better get you back to town
what about the other girls I got them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is this like the one I'll be playing in
Utah it's quite similar I supervised the
installation myself the action that
won't delay your going with it no I'm
leaving this morning there's nothing I
can do here that's right well Mary
you'll make a fine organist for that
church be very satisfying to you I think
it's just a job to me oh it's not quite
the attitude for going into church work
I'm not taking the vows I'm only gonna
play the organ why you want more than
that of course it doesn't pay much but
well at least it's a start
are you driving by Bentley to see your
folks no I can't I I must hurry I've got
to leave I'm gonna drive straight
through Mary it takes more than
intellect to be a musician put your soul
into it a little okay
good luck Mary stop by and see us the
next time you're in thank you but I'm
never coming back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I help you fill it up all right
anything else lady could you tell me
what that big structure is back a few
miles by the lake oh you mean the old
bathhouse yeah that used to be a pretty
ritzy place in the old days and the lake
went down and they made a dance hall out
of it
then they put those buildings up out
there and made some sort of a carnival
there for a while that's years ago
though just stands out there now I see I
have an address here of a rooming house
could you direct me oh sure
well that's just right over here a
little ways been saving that for ya
since I got your letter
gotta render that yesterday but wanted
oh yeah it's fine
it's just about what I expected I knew
you'd like it
there's ain't no regular room in the
house you know I only got you and mr.
Linden across the hall
each rooms got its own private bathroom
too you can take all the bads you want
I'm not one to fuss about things like
that thank you I think I'll be quite
comfortable well hope you'll stay alive
I'm downstairs in the back part of the
house so there's anything else you need
I guess I'll have to wait morning
all right good night mrs. Thomas
[Music]
[Music]
and this Miss Henry is our pride and joy
you know this was made in the same town
where I've been studying of course
that's where we heard about you oh by
the way you have found a place to stay
yes I have a room good well we hope
you're going to like it here
we're not the largest church in this
area of course but we have a nice
congregation we'll have to have some
sort of reception they want to meet you
couldn't we just skip that skip that I
don't suppose it's an absolute necessity
I don't know what some of the ladies
will say if they say I'm a fine organist
that should be enough shouldn't it well
yes of course we'll let it go at that
for the time being but my dear you
cannot live in isolation from the human
race you know
mind if I try this now I want you to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll be next door
if you need
[Applause]
[Music]
favorables Terry soul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you see nothing nothing at all
I've practiced the whole afternoon and
it's got me in a mood you need some
fresh air
I've got to make a call out past a lake
would you like to come along for the
ride you know that old pavilion out
there mm-hmm will we pass it go right by
it stop and look at it if you like I
would with you along good
[Music]
[Music]
this used to be quite a place it's been
deserted for a long time now
when you take me in oh goodness no it
isn't safe out there anymore that's why
they put up this barrier be very easy to
step around it
what attraction could there be for you
out there I'm not sure I'm a reasonable
person I don't know maybe I want to
satisfy myself that the place is nothing
more than it appears to be would you
take me out there Oh Allah has placed it
off limits wouldn't be very seemly for a
minister to break the law would it no
maybe I can come back some other time
shall we go along now
[Music]
organ playing must take a long time
you've been gone most the whole day I
went for a long drive in the country
with my new boss and elderly minister oh
that must have been a kick in the head I
learned that from the boarder mr. Linden
you get your supper oh I forgot
oh there's ain't no boarding house but I
got some coffee and the sandwich makings
left I could bring me a thumb-up after a
while good I'll be taking one of those
bags you're so generous with take as
many as you want I ain't going to make a
fuss about a thing like that
[Music]
I thought doing mrs. Thomas yeah yeah
fun when you ask me I'm John Linden I'm
your neighbor right across the hall nice
to meet you would you excuse me yeah
yeah I just wondering I do I do it it's
stand right there
[Music]
[Applause]
I forgot to introduce myself I'm Mary
Hennen oh yeah I know
I heard you tell mrs. Thomas you haven't
ate anything yet
oh yeah I just thought you'd be enabling
olive I haven't eaten anything either
I just thought we had asked out to
dinner oh that's very thoughtful of you
but I can't accept I think I know I know
you haven't met or anything yet but I
just don't have to excuse me look
there's a nice restaurant you know right
down the street and I just thought well
I'm just kind of guy who doesn't like to
eat by himself
I've made arrangements to eat my room
tonight hey if you change your mind you
just holler let's cut a lot so many
goodnight mr. Lennon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
miss Henry its miss Thomas who's the man
in the hall oh you must mean mr. Lyndon
he has the room across the hall no I
mean the other one there is no other me
and you and mr. Lyndon us three is all
there is in this house but but you might
have passed him out there you're needing
this food well the death eatin makes you
jumpy sometimes maybe you heard the
board's pop or something he's old houses
creak worse than my knees I didn't hear
him mrs. Thomas I saw him now don't talk
that way
I don't sleep so good as it is it's
these old houses they they're big enough
so that you did hide a man in every
corner you just got a knock let your
imagination run away and you're going
out there
there's nobody there now you just go and
eat that sandwich I made for you don't
drink the coffee if coffee keeps you
awake
it won't Coffee never keeps me away
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
well good morning
I heard your alum I know you be up guess
what I got hi I can't imagine just what
it takes to start the day off right I'll
make it in my room you know it saves me
having to go out and get dressed up I
had to get dressed to come over here
anyway Oh looks just like what I need
man two cups of coffee coming up hey I
guess you took her on last night about
me coming to your door and all I'm not a
very sociable person ordinary how can I
resist inducement like this
what come on I don't know all those big
words I'm just an ordinary guy works
nowhere house that's all like pretty
good money though Hey look I got a
couple of shots leftover from last night
you want a little bit in yours ah no
thanks it's not the recommended
breakfast for church organist oh is that
what you do
hey mean they they pay somebody to play
the organ in church some churches do hey
I hope you don't mind about this I just
didn't know you're a church woman to me
a church is just a place of business
well it's a funny way to look at what
people seem shocked because I took a job
in a church and reg I regard it simply
as a job I'm a professional organist I
play for pay that's all thinking like
that don't I give you nightmares strange
you should say that it's a matter of
fact not for that reason mind you but I
I had the strangest feeling last night
yeah hey kind of a lost night myself
funny world is so different in the
daylight
but in the dark your fantasies get so
out of hand in the daylight everything
falls back into place again let's have
no more nights or let's make the more
interesting huh say yeah how'd you get
to be a church organist I studied it in
college I could have gone at college
yeah it's a pretty good football but
they wanted me to take a lot of classes
and things you know well they're that
way well I'm just a spot as the next guy
yeah but I just didn't think with our
teacher in school you know and the thing
I hated most was principal products
principal product you know you're like a
principal product of Brazil
coffee beans a snake or I feel like that
yeah I was a school I couldn't care less
no what I cared about was girls didn't
they offer a course in that would have
done that I would have graduated
what's the matter can you still taste
the coffee come on what you think I'm an
alcoholic
look I just like to start the day off in
a good mood that's all you must be
hilarious by noon look I'm just a kind
of a guy employee is one you know the
happy we're good come on condi e make
you a morning happy this morning you're
exactly what I needed
I don't need me in the evening - you
just don't know it yet I'll rinse off
these cuffs Hana just spoils the flavor
for tomorrow thank you for the coffee
it was unsanitary but delicious should
have put some of the germ killer inside
well I hate leaves early I think you can
get through the door you know you cut
the wrong impression of me well I meant
because you had so many things to carry
Oh like I said I hate leave well it's
been a pleasure mr. linen
but I'm sure you have to get to work
don't you know the whole day for you for
shopping does the hem hang right in back
we might change the hemline a little the
drape is just fine otherwise it looks
very nice I'm sure it isn't very chic to
take the second dress but I like it we
altered a little here to make it
straight all the way around there do you
want to go back to your dressing room
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I believe I have you deliver the dress
if you don't mind I did say I'd take it
[Music]
what's the matter with it what's the
matter with everyone why don't they
answer me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is it Batman I didn't mean any harm
I just stopped to get a drink no it was
that man there was someone else there a
strange man was back look look you've
had a fright hysteria won't solve
anything now control yourself
look I'm dr. Sandra my office is right
across the street there you've had a
shock if you would like my assistance
I'll be glad to offer it thank you
could I come with you now certainly I'll
take her over to my office we'll see
that she's all right
it was more than just not being able to
hear anything or make contact with
anyone it was as though as though for a
time I didn't exist as though I had no
place in the world no part of the life
around me and then you saw this this man
yes you'll excuse my back but I wanted
to get some of that written down I must
have been talking for an hour anything
else anything you haven't told me that's
all there is that's the whole story
he's been following me that's all there
is to it it isn't
that's simple though is it what do you
mean he can hardly been in the park this
afternoon or one of us men would have
seen him and that made in the hallway
you said yourself that landlady came up
a minute later and she didn't see him
did she what are you driving at it's
been less than a week since you were in
a car that crashed into the river how
you get out of that no one seems to know
but that experience must have been a
serious emotional shock you think I
imagined all of it don't you you think
I'm insane I didn't say that I don't
mean that I'm a competent person if
anything I'm a realist I'm not given to
imagining anything hogwash all of us
imagine things have you never heard two
men talking behind your back and imagine
they were talking about you have you
ever imagined you saw someone you knew
and walked up to them and found they
were a perfect stranger I don't see what
this has to do with it the point is this
our imaginations play tricks on us
they often misinterpret what we see in
here do you agree
I suppose so if that can happen in
ordinary times go a step further look
what can happen in a high fever or
following a serious emotional shock
doesn't seem possible that I could have
imagined all of it does this man this
figure resemble anyone you've ever known
an acquaintance or your father no you
have a boyfriend here
oh no and I have no desire for one never
know I'm surprised by myself saying that
but it's true I have no desire for the
close company of other people have you
always felt this way I know don't you
want to join in the things that other
people do share the experiences of other
people I don't think capable being very
close to people I do feel that perhaps I
am trying to reach out for those other
things do you feel guilty wanting them I
don't understand you I'm not a
psychiatrist and perhaps I'm being
clumsy at all this but I am suggesting
that perhaps this figure represents a
guilt feeling oh that's ridiculous
maybe frankly I don't know well I know
one thing my imagination is playing
tricks on me
I'm gonna put a stop to it you're a very
strong-willed person aren't you
I survive if that's what you mean that
old pavilion out by the lake somehow you
associate it with all this don't you
I could go out there I could put an end
to that too I could go on now don't be
hasty if it is all my imagination I
could put a stop to it maybe but at
least someone should be with you now I
can't assure you I'm a person of strong
will and the time to go out there is now
and if I have to I can go alone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
say yeah I don't want to get turned down
again
I was thinking asking you out today I
stopped for a bite to eat on the way in
anyway I have to practice at the church
look good toss about a fight to get that
wouldn't go someplace and dance or
something I'm sorry I'm not much for
dancing hey you mind if I ask you a
question
I won't know until I hear it what are
you afraid of man no I'm not afraid of
men you seem sort of cold this morning
when I brought you the coffee friendly
this morning I needed company maybe
we'll need company tonight it's better
than walking home alone yes it is I
should be finished around 9:00 would
that be alright that's okay by me say
yeah I'll see you in church
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
profane sacrilege
what are you playing in this church have
you no respect do you feel no reverence
and I feel sorry for you and your lack
of soul this ordered the music of this
church these things have meaning and
significance to us I assume they did to
you but without this awareness I'm
afraid you cannot be our organist in
conscience I must ask you to resign
that does not mean that I am abandoning
you nor should you turn your back on the
church there is help here and I urge you
to accept it
well hi there I've been waiting an awful
long time for you my car's just over
there I know just the right place to do
[Music]
it's a matter don't you drink either not
really not really how else is there if
you don't drink really answer me then
now me I not only drink really I really
drink what's the matter
you like the music even like it fine oh
you don't like it you don't like to fast
and you don't like to drink you don't
like for a man I'll hold you close
that's it innit
I didn't say that you haven't said
anything all evening fine ago play that
song again you liked it so much
hey Johnny who's a doll nobody you know
cheating oh come on now you've been
holding out on me
that's not the kind of pick you usually
drag around you couldn't lick in your
job she's out of your class you want a
bet
lay off huh I got something on the stove
Batman listen I'll help you put it over
I don't want her to think I even know
creeps like you good luck
me that one you know yeah
he's a college fella yeah tell me about
this girls you wanted to meet me wanted
me to meet her what'd you tell him I
said how could I you're my date you know
[Music]
said you didn't seem to enjoy my company
much that's not true I really appreciate
your taking me out this evening had a
miserable night if you forget it come on
here join a party drink up I paid good
money for that stuff and ain't poison
I'm sorry if i annoy you you know I
don't get you first you stand me off
that's okay that's class think you got
something you just holding back no
everything I say is okay you're a mouse
yesterday I didn't care
tonight I want to be with you me just
with anybody with you
[Music]
why aren't you all out but maybe you
want to be alone oh you're all content
what you want I like being with you
really I do I don't want to be alone
tonight I want to be near you you mean
that yes
[Music]
why don't you me get out of here you
know my room's only a couple of feet
from yours likely to get very far from
me I
[Music]
no girls no back-of-house won't hear
nothing honey
you don't want to go in there all by
yourself do you stockin it's lonely in
there you don't have to be alone and I
he just let me come in a while I let me
stay with you I didn't want to be alone
do you
I'm sorry you asked me and yeah it's
like me a little huh
hey what's the matter with you what's
going on around here what's the matter
with you man's after me
you gotta stop your he's after me again
not me sister that's just what I need
get mixed up with some girl is off her
rocker
[Music]
[Music]
when you find out doctor not very much
I'm afraid I'm sure glad you just
happened around I was gonna call
somebody but I was afraid you'd have to
pay the bill I came on purpose I've been
thinking about her ever since she left
my office yesterday what's she been up
to only the devil knows that I heard her
movin things all around that room all
night never heard such goings on and she
wouldn't let me in her room this morning
she's a strange one mm-hmm
she absolutely refuses my help I can't
say that I blame her there's something
about her that completely baffles me
I've urged her to call upon me if she
feels she needs help
and I hope she will I can't let her stay
in this house you won't have to worry
about that she's determined to leave the
city and she wants to get away as soon
as possible I hope she does leave I hope
she can
decided to leave did you
where you going I can't refund none of
your week's rent when you go off like
that
[Music]
[Music]
sounds like your transmission can you
pull it up on the rack
[Music]
okay really take off well I have to
check it first would you like to get out
yeah I just sit here sure say it
yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when is not eastbound us
when is the next bus leave I must get on
[Music]
I want to get out of here I want to get
away from here
[Music]
[Music]
eastbound bus loading nine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why can't I hate anything were you help
me I need your help just a moment please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I came to you doctor because you're my
my last hope if you don't help yeah I
had to go back there he's he's trying to
take me back so worried doctor you've
got to tell me what to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
because still over there and then a foot
then she leading up to here
and then nothing
[Music]
[Music]